trying to brag or anything but
is it getting hot in here
they say diamonds are a girl's best
friend and now you don't have to depend
on mother nature to find the stone of
your dreams joining me now is amisha
president of alter created diamonds
welcome thank you i mean
can we just talk about this bling that
you put on me i have these amazing hoop
earrings and these are altered diamonds
tell me a little bit about them these
are ultra created diamonds these are
diamonds grown above the earth in a
controlled enviro environment
and mounted
and designed in recycled gold
so there is no harm cost to the
environment
and there a far better value those are
beautiful 10 carat diamond earrings
i'm going to choke
don't take carrots what are you kidding
and then they put this on my wrist tell
me a little bit about what you do at
ultra diamonds tell us how this comes to
fruition sure
the technology that was born in 1951
for growing diamonds took about 70 years
for us to bring to the marketplace
today between 2010 2015 we were able to
start growing gem quality
finest quality diamonds above the earth
the brand came to market in 2016 as the
first created diamond brand and today we
can proudly say that the consumers have
a choice
for a fine jewel
in recycled gold that they can be
conscious of and we're beautiful
now let's talk about like comparing two
to diamonds made of the earth what are
the price points we're talking about
here what's is it a big difference is it
not a big difference it's actually very
simple
you get almost twice the size
for the same price okay sign me
how long do these take to create
so it takes about for a one carat
diamond it takes about 600 hours to
create oh wow so like 24 days okay the
overall process is about eight weeks
uh in a controlled chamber
a diamond grows from a diamond so that's
one thing a lot of times people get
confused is like oh do these girl from
some chemical no
you take a slice of a diamond as thin as
your hair yes and we placed in a
proprietary chamber that's as big as
like a six person dining table
the facility is about two football field
size
and under controlled temperature
we grow these diamonds from pure carbon
that is just the the process is
fascinating to me and look at this one
is it just me or the lights in here or
are these
more sparkly than
actual diamonds because i've seen real
diamonds haven't necessarily worn them
but these are so brilliant and beautiful
is is that just me or no it's a great
observation
because you said a few things
are the more brilliant
all ultra created diamonds are type 2a
a term not used at much on the consumer
level type 2a are the two percent of the
world's finest and purest diamonds wow
topped with all our diamond cutting is
robotic
which brings out the finest polish and
as a company we hold 49 patents
to cut for best for brilliance so you're
seeing a combination of all of them
together that it really is fascinating
if people are interested in being
socially environmentally and financially
conscious here you've got to check out
ultra diamonds how do people get in
touch with you
alter.nyc we're a new york company
and you can reach us at alter.invicee or
our
retailers
like borsheims
hyde park the variety of retailers in
the country i am telling you these are
brilliant i am now in my heaven kendall
you had yours i have mine we're all
happy it's a perfect day for both of us